bonjour bienvenue mon atelier bonjour On
va faire du pilote aujourd'hui c'est pas
une salle de torture non non
qui a déjà pris de la drogue ici
[Rires]
les gars
la magie de Noël opère tiens moi un
journaliste qui fait tout le monde s'ils
font des enquêtes sur moi de partout
pour savoir si je prends de la drogue
alors je peux lui dire c'est pas la
peine de chercher je crois pas dedans je
suis agité de nature
tu vois ma mère t'as compris
pas mais par contre on vous emmerde
voilà
[Applaudissements]
à 40 ans après la sortie du film de
Spielberg la marionnette dit-il le petit
extraterrestre gentil va être vendu aux
enchères pour la petite histoire et vous
le savez c'est dans ity qu'on a
découvert la crise droubari mort elle
n'avait que 7 ans dans le film midi dans
le film
pas dans la marionnette
[Musique]
et il existe
[Rires]
moi aussi je prends ma grosse voix
d'hiver pour annoncer julia Vignali
comme tous les garçons quand je suis
revenu je vais mourir quoi
je manifeste officiellement contre la
climatisation ici au Qatar ce matin je
sors il y a du vent mon petit parquet
pour les bonbons petit déjeuner etc et
donc là maintenant j'en ai marre ma mare
il faut arrêter de nous raconter des
bêtises il fait froid au Qatar Pascal
voilà on nous a menti les couleurs des
Lions de l'Atlas sont partout dans les
rues de Rabat maillot bonnet casquette
drapeau trône dans toutes les vitrines
et l'ascension historique du Maroc en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde fait la
une de tous les journaux une atmosphère
inédite qui fait même chavirer les
expatriés français j'étais chez les
champs
mais partout c'était il courait enfin
médina
c'était intéressant mais mercredi soir
les gens ils vont pas sortir les
supporters français 6 mois par exemple
j'ai des enfants je dis à mes enfants
vous sortez pas manger danger danger
je vais ici depuis presque 20 ans et mon
cœur est ici donc pour moi ça va être
vraiment un déchirement parce que je
peux pas choisir le conseil c'est comme
disait Gad Elmaleh c'est comme si son
père jouait contre sa mère c'est la même
chose pour moi il décide de se faire
tatouer le logo de l'équipe de France
orné de trois étoiles et oui on le voit
à l'image Teddy c'est fait tatouer la
troisième étoile donc ça marche
maintenant bien en haut de la cuisse
juste en dessous de la fesse
précise-t-il à nos confrères la séance
de dédicace de François Hollande a dévié
sur le mollet d'une admiratrice il faut
dire que la jeune femme a une citation
de l'ancien président tatoué là un
passage culte pour son anglais
approximatif
et au final on n'a jamais
tous les jours
lourdonne-moi si c'est un chèque je le
prends c'est
pas non plus tous les jours donne-moi ta
liste au Père Noël excusez-moi c'est mon
conseiller financier tu peux me le dire
c'est une demande un peu particulière tu
vas pas bouffer le cul de Daniel au
QI de Bulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait comment ça se passe on la met
dessus
il faudrait peut-être créer une petite
plaie